the people who there are a few people
who agreed to to to answer an exam
question that Eric Eric and I composed
and that's how it's characterized by
Keith Grable said don't you have enough
students so maybe not or you guys are
exceptionally strong students so while
there while they're being seated let me
let me read to you the charge that the
that this August August panel was given
so they were they were asked to reflect
on the following questions so here we go
I will read the preamble I'll just get
right to the questions two of them which
they're there they're gonna give brief
comments on because we have many but
actually whatever they want to do is
fine with me
first what interesting non obvious and
important thing have you learned
either from your own research or that of
others about legislators representation
or parties question mark we are looking
here for something one thing to be we
have to give it some shape that you
think of as a reasonably secure Lea
established empirical or theoretical
finding okay that's the first part this
is why it's like a comp question to what
is the most interesting and important
open question in the study of
legislators representation or parties
okay then this is the most ridiculous
part would you be willing to prepare an
approximately three to four minute
answer okay right that's ridiculous
obviously but but what can you do you
have to say something so they're gonna
say whatever they're gonna say no one's
going to stop them but that that was the
that was the charge and and so I'd like
to now turn it over to to this I mean
shockingly great great collection of
legislators or parties or representation
and in fact as I will say about comets
tomorrow I never did take so I don't
know quite a lie on here by driving down
this morning listening to a PG woodhouse
story on tape and thought about what I
wanted to say so what I think I've
learned from reading is how complicated
the idea and practice of representation
is and I want to make a couple comments
about what I think is problematic about
representation as practice at least in
the United States Congress or the United
States legislatures and then a few
comments about what I think we don't
really know I haven't really thought
hard enough about representation is
obviously and you know I start with
Madison Federalist ten or various
Federalist Papers and work my way
through sort of a science more recently
clearly representation as a governance
structure is necessary if you've got
more than 50 100 several hundred people
so this is not an argument that we ought
to have deliberative democracy or direct
democracy or something else instead
seems to me representation is essential
it's also of course essential if you
have more than a few very simple ideas
that have to be decided about either we
have many ideas or the ideas themselves
are complicated or they're interactive
in certain ways so this is not an
argument for referenda so it's not about
you against representation but I think
what we know is that representation
again is very complicated and not
terribly effective it's not only
necessary it's also desirable and again
this is kind of straight out of Madison
it expands the arena within what you can
Governance think back to Federalist 10
you can expand the number of states in
the geographic arena it brings in many
more perspectives than almost any other
system could effectively do so it
filters the views of constituents that's
more Hamill to than Madison but it's
against there in the Federalist Papers
it provides the sustained focus on
complex issues which themselves are
difficult to make decisions on and which
are interactive and which change over
time so the logic of Trustees is I think
a very serious part of representation we
know what with that but it's deeply
inefficient and in many ways deeply
undemocratic and perhaps even be
ineffective as a structure of governance
for example I mean if you have a single
member of Geographic district is of
course you mostly have the United States
roughly speaking half of the potential
of the constituents don't get the person
they want if you have a landslide maybe
you have 55 58 60 percent support but
still two fists other people don't get
the one so it's a very simple purely
arithmetic level it's a sort of non
democratic or ineffective or inefficient
kind of democratic process
lots of substantive topics get bundled
in single-member first-past-the-post
white districts in ways that people
wouldn't necessarily bundle them on
their own
I learned this probably from Bob Lane
who made me think about it in Italy
partly for my own interview work partly
from lots of other work that other
people have done I mean for example two
simple examples of that social
conservatives have rather to my surprise
relatively effectively but also
uncomfortably allied with market
conservatives who are often closer to
libertarian in what we call the
Republican Party over the last you know
thirty forty years I mean it's worked
but it doesn't make much sense if you
stand back why you would think a deeply
religious kind of conservative ought to
be in the same kind of party as a deeply
libertarian or market-oriented
conservative they are and they've
figured out how to make
work pretty well but there's no
intrinsic reason why they ought to be in
this ending party when you vote for
representative that's the bundle you get
and so you can't pull them apart on the
liberal side there and you see the
tensions in the in the Democratic Party
on this that sort of liberals who are
very concerned about American
low-skilled workers disproportionately
but not necessarily people of color are
also bundled in the same party as people
who are advocates of increased
immigration of low-skilled workers
so you see competition among
constituencies within the Democratic
Party there's no obvious reason why they
ought to be in the same party but they
are and that's the only choice you have
as a voter so just and the other reason
I think representation is profoundly
inefficient or ineffective in a
democratic sense is that it's simply
impossible for most people to express or
see expressed in their legislature a
variety of their own identities that
matter to them so if you're a white male
you have a liar larger proportion of
representation if you're a black male or
a black female or a white female or an
atheist or a deeply religious Muslim it
doesn't have to be race and gender but
that's typically how we think of these
identity questions class almost by
definition people who are not at least
middle or upper middle class are never
represented in their identity is never
represented in a legislature so
representation it seems to me what one
of the things we know starting again
with the Federalist Papers but through
lots and lots of political science is it
it's necessary it's desirable and it's
not doesn't work very well from a
perspective of kind of democratic
participation and democratic
decision-making so what are the open
questions that I would like us to think
more about collectively grow out of what
I just said
so what there's an empirical question
normative question on a political
question are the empirical questions can
in fact representation be made any more
effective in the Lange
I'm using any more efficient any better
ad in fact representing either a larger
proportion of people or a larger
proportion of things people care about
or disaggregating things so that people
can get the things they care about but
not some of the things that don't care
about it that they oppose we're not
likely to change the electoral structure
the United States them to put a
proportional representation process we
need more comparative is to tell me
whether actually I would in fact be more
representative in the ways that I'm
talking about but that isn't going to
happen at least in a large-scale sense
in the United States so it seems to me
an empirical question is are there any
kind of other kinds of institutional
fixes cumulative voting more ofrenda
some other way of thinking about
representation within the existing
constitutional structure and with any
kind of plausible political system that
would resolve some of the issues that
I'm talking about the other question I
think within the empirical realm is does
anybody who has any power actually have
any incentive to seek institutional
fixes if anybody were to concur that
this is a problem as I'm saying the
answer is no of course by definition if
they have institutional power or a
political power they have managed to
work their way through this
institutional system and I don't think
it's very effective it works for them so
is there a reason really to think that
anything is dramatically is gonna change
but I think political scientists ought
to spend a little more time thinking
about what could perhaps be different
and seeing a please around the edges we
could do something different
normatively and how much is there a
problem of the kind of what I'm calling
inefficient or ineffective
representation well one answer is not
very much there are lots of other things
the other we're worrying about most
people don't actually care very much as
Bob Dole put it in new governs
homo politico's is a fairly small
category people who do care do in fact
have access
two representatives if not
representation there is in fact a lot of
slack in the system also revert back to
who governs people can find
representatives outside their own
district so that again african-americans
can find people and if you have black
legislators they will see themselves
responsible for the black population as
a whole in addition to their own
decision so maybe it's not that big a
deal for things I'm worrying about don't
matter to very many people there are at
least short-term fixes or alternatively
it is a big deal
maybe if people felt represented rent
represented more they would care more
maybe that the cause of our goes in the
other direction
that they don't feel represented so
therefore they don't care rather than
they don't care so therefore they don't
worry about representation there we know
from RT Gillan's Larry bar tells Newman
and Griffin there's a whole lot of work
that shows in fact considerable and
systematic and persistent and important
inequality of representation by the
criteria would expect race and class
most obviously but again also gender
non-citizens the deeply religious
atheists there's lots of categories for
whom we might want to worry the
representation simply doesn't work very
well
final question that I think we could do
more work on is politically what would
it make any difference if somehow
representation became more efficient or
more effective um
again there's two answers here one is
know that there are fundamental
budgetary constraints there are party
discipline there are foreign policy
imperatives there's a variety of things
though it basically would say that we
elected people differently if we had
representation somehow differently
wouldn't make very much difference in
what at the margins but not in any
serious way the other answer is yes
human agency matters that if you think
you have a representative you care more
about politics you are more engaged if a
representative is chosen somehow
differently and thinks of constituents
differently they would actually behave
differently or simply of different
degree or office they might behave
differently so I think there's a few
things we know and lots of things we
don't know about representation
Thanks the picture of American politics
that's coming to focus for me in the
last 40 years or the last 39 years since
I showed up down the street as a 17 year
old is literally a picture and it's one
that entails all the aspects of the
political system that may who has taught
us so much about that Allen squeezed
into his exam question for us and bring
a copy but you've all seen various
versions of it there are lots of them
floating around on to my embarrassment
don't know who is the first person who
actually presented this sort of picture
but it's a picture in which the
horizontal dimension has something about
the Preferences of constituencies
whether it's measured by survey data or
measured by presidential election votes
or something from left to right along an
axis and the horizontal dimension has
something about the policy choices or
policy outcomes of individual
representatives or of the process
separately for Republicans and Democrats
and what that picture looks like is that
there are two lines both of which are
gently upward sloping and with a big gap
between them that I think is kind of the
fundamental picture that you most want
to convey to a beginning student about
what the American political system is
like there's a less famous analog of
that picture for presidents which I take
from the macro polity although if you
read the text of the macro polity they
don't make a big deal this they have an
analysis that relates the mood of the
country to the policy output of the the
White House which if you actually look
at the coefficients and the book has
very much that same character there's a
upward slope which is to say that policy
is more liberal when the country is more
liberal and more conservative when the
mood of the country is more conservative
but that effect is really pretty small
and magnitude by comparison with the
difference that you observe in policy
outcomes between a typical Democratic
president and a typical Republican
president so I think in terms of the
actual picture you would get something
if you
that way very much like the picture
that's become pretty familiar for
Congress that picture has sharpened over
the last 40 years but if somebody had
sat down in 1973 or 1974 and drawn the
picture it really would not have looked
greatly different you would have seen
that same qualitative picture but we
didn't see it then people weren't
looking for it then why is that well I
think a large part of the issue a large
part of the explanation has to do with
the point that David just touched on in
his charming little autobiographical
sketch Anthony downs that we had this
view about how elections ought to work
in which there was a very powerful
moderating force that would push elected
officials to the middle and I think
really one of the most important aspects
of what we've learned over the last 40
years is that that moderating push is
really quite weak
it's especially weak now but I think it
was probably pretty weak even in the
period where elected officials were
behaving more moderately they were
behaving more moderately in ways that
were consistent with down's theory but I
think probably not for the reasons that
Downes was talking about the other point
I think that was important was the
examples that we could point to or think
prominently about in American politics
at that period of the elections
Goldwater and McGovern in particular
which seemed to for many people
crystallized the lesson that ideological
extremism would be punished by the
Elector I think we now see pretty
clearly that Goldwater and McGovern both
lost mostly not because they were
ideologically extremists but because
they were running in times where the
incumbent was benefited by a strong
economy and so there was a kind of miss
attribution of those outcomes that
reinforced this idea that ideological
moderation was a big pressure that was
coming from the electorate so now I
think we both convinced ourselves that
that's really not such a strong pressure
and so we preserved members of Congress
behaving in different ways as the
panelists this morning have described
but why is that I think the first
explanation that was reached for by
people who were inside Congress and
we're looking at the institutions within
Congress was that party whipping and the
party organization
within Congress was a big deal I think
you know that's important but it's not
the main explanation for why these guys
behave the way they do the second
explanation that people have reached to
that I think is really fundamentally
consistent in its spirit with the Downs
and logic is that there are primary
electorates out there and they're the
ones we're forcing these guys to behave
more extremely than they otherwise would
again I think there's something
important to that but I don't think
that's most of the story probably either
for one thing if you look at the people
who are voting in these primaries
they're not as Extreme as the guys in
Congress sound so I think there's
probably more to it than that but one of
the open questions I think we should be
working on is to understand better how
it is that primaries do when they do
force this centrifugal effect another
big category of explanations that's
received a lot less attention but I
think would be deserving of a lot more
work it's not something that we can do
very well I think with the sharp
analytical toolkit that David described
will require a different kind of work
but that's to understand who these
people are and what it is that they want
and how they get to the point where they
could be elected to office in the first
place the processes of political
socialization and political recruitment
and the broader infrastructure of
American political culture in which they
come up I think has big effects on who
it is that gets to that point and what
it is that they want to do and my guess
is that a lot of what they do is stuff
that they do not because they're single
monument seekers of reelection but
because they actually care a lot about
politics and policy and they do what
they think is right and so understanding
better why they think it is that these
things are right and good I think is an
important part of our agenda
I came to Yale in the fall of 1968 I was
going to study Western European politics
and I enrolled in gel upon bars class
and I lasted two weeks before I realized
that there was no way I was going to get
to that level I just didn't have it and
so I bailed out started having long
lunches with David may you and taking
Jerry Kramer's econometrics course and
my life went on to a different path but
with Joe sitting here I want to report
to him that I now teach comparative
political behavior it's only taken me 40
years to learn what you would have
taught me in a semester and so there's
there's been some redemption in the end
after all what I want to talk about
today is very close to what my two smart
friends to my right have just talked
about and that's representation and some
of the empirical difficulties there I've
had the pleasure recently of going back
to the Miller Stokes work on this topic
including a fugitive but now in hand
draft of the early chapters of that book
and it led to some rethinking on my part
that I want to report here just briefly
we import the July rhetoric we take it
as obvious that there that if you hold
elections the members of Congress who
are elected will line up with the
Preferences of their constituencies and
even those of us who know better when I
listen to myself I hear myself slipping
into into that into that language but as
Miller and Stokes showed and as
subsequent research across Europe has
demonstrated that correlation is
typically not too bad but it's sure not
overwhelming and it's often quite
miserable and there are instances of
political parties the Republicans of the
1950s being a case in point where the
positions they were taking in Congress
really didn't match up very well at all
with the people voting for them and
there were examples of that across many
other countries and time periods as well
now we know that issues don't make much
difference in in elections most of the
time so there and yeah and yet in it an
electoral connection and surely exists
and as Mark Newman was stressing this
morning members of Congress worked very
hard on that on that score and there are
certainly egregious examples
in American political history and the
history of other countries in which the
the electoral connection worked in the
way that our fourth of july' rhetoric
says it should so Miller and Stokes and
their famous article 50 years ago this
spring talked about Brooks Hayes who
represented the Little Rock area and got
into trouble for being an honest broker
in civil rights matters in Arkansas at
that point and was thrown out of office
for being too moderate these days it's
not clear how often that occurs hiking
the Appalachian Trail parently is
insufficient you you get put back into
office if you're a suitable
representative of your party so this as
we heard this morning so this process
induces some kind of policy correlation
but not all that impressive of one and
how is it forged exactly and what is the
causal mechanism there that causes it to
work pretty well most of the time but
sometimes to just break down and I think
we don't we don't nearly we don't know
nearly enough about that is party
identification central to that for
example so as we continue to talk as a
profession about the electoral
connection as paths that that many
people have have written about and David
may it was influential for so many of us
in in in writing about it I still
remember the very early draft paper in
which he was writing about dad as he as
he mentioned it was my my first in in my
first intimation that even terrific
scholars who write wonderfully don't
necessarily have fabulous first drafts
and that that was I thought I was the
only one who who did that and it evolved
very rapidly and into the into the
wonderful prose and powerful argument
that
that we're all used to but what he typed
that when he wrote it the first weekend
wasn't all the way to what it to what it
later became and that made a huge
impression on me at the time so in in
what I want to say is again similar to
what was just been said by my two
colleagues but it is that we not get too
lost in thinking about the causal forces
at work here important as those are but
that we also spend some time thinking
about how well the resulting process
gives people the the representation that
they that they want and one thing it
seems to me that needs a little more
attention than we've given ideas of
remark that Francis Lieber made Francis
Lieber was a refugee from the 1848
revolutions in in Germany came to the
United States couldn't get was the first
real political scientist scientists
couldn't get a job in at any of the Toni
institutions and wound up at the
University of South Carolina and he
wrote about the importance of political
parties in shaping what their adherents
think and it seems to me that's been
lost a bit and that thinking about the
degree to which representation doesn't
flow in quite the way we think it does
on the 4th of July but rather flows to
some degree in in the other direction
thinking about that seems to me to be
quite useful in spite of fact I also
remember about professor Lieber that
living in South Carolina at the time he
did he knew John C Calhoun and like a
good political scientist he wrote
constituent letters to his senator
trying to help that person understand
how they should be voting and Lee Burke
kept writing about you know slavery
really isn't as good as you think it is
and maybe there's a metaphor there for
how influential political scientists are
I gotta say first off that I hate round
tables area ditional its decision in the
central time zone skill set nonetheless
there's an assignment and I do what I do
so I wrote out my answer question one
most interesting non-obvious or
important thing you have learned it will
come as no surprise that my answers
reflect my tastes and what I'm currently
working on so I don't intend to to
defend that this is the most interesting
or the most important thing we've all
learned but this is an interesting thing
that I've learned and that is the
following legislative rules precedents
and even many norms are remarkably
durable even when they are very
conspicuously and Dodgers I'll repeat
that because it's a little bit one
legislative rules precedence and even
many norms are remarkably durable even
when they are very conspicuously
endogenous reason I find this
generalization interesting is because
thinking about it is thinking about it
and working on it has such a broad
assortment of spillover effects on other
aspects of life many of them not
political so I just give you a few
examples from an early age I learned
about in dodging 80 of rules by
inventing the playing games with my
brother and usually these involved a
piece of wood with some spherical object
and took on very very ornate and baroque
rule-based features another example is
collective choices and even family where
N equals four think about it for a
minute we've got a collective choice
with for voters you've got a filibuster
pivot a veto pivot and a median pivot
that's all the same person and that
leads to some interesting possibilities
and the outcome of which is we don't
vote
more seriously endogenous collective
choice is useful in doing things like
thinking about the trade-offs and
teaching about the trade-offs between
utilitarianism and fairness when
teaching business ethic business ethics
and likewise contemplating the trust
foundation for paper currency of a
global economy these seemingly unrelated
things are actually related so I'm not
sure whether this will sound silly
self-important or may be deranged but I
actually think that if one gets a good
enough handle on in dodging 80 of
congressional procedures he could pretty
much solve most of the important
problems in life so the most interesting
and important open question I didn't try
to shirk on the assignment but it just
came out that a 2 follows directly from
anyone so because it's essentially the
same answer I'll spin it a little bit
differently one thing I've learned over
the years as a congressional is that as
congressional scholars get older they
get increasingly curmudgeon in the
amount of Congress I'm getting older
so before warned that the premise of
this answer is a cynical view of the
conventional wisdom and you don't have
to buy into it a hundred percent for the
question to be good
I myself buy into it only about 83
percent the average US legislator seems
to be short-sighted in almost every way
rather than fight the long fight he
tends to cave to pressure from special
interests rather than invest
institutionally invest in
institutionally productive activities in
the capital that has may use
institutional maintenance for example
she allocates a large fraction of finite
time and effort to the next election
travel fund raising homestyle activities
at seven because extra legislative
opportunity costs members of Congress
are able to study issues and develop
influence in
apparently grounded in political
expertise at best they bone up just
enough to get in front of them nearest
camera with the vacuous top party
talking points a la paper that Francis
presented this morning then it's off to
the next fundraiser home for the next
weekend or maybe on to the next quick
kill issue which means another position
taking opportunity rather than making
policy so when finally it comes down to
moving they're just filing when it comes
down to passing legislation there are
also ample opportunities for
short-sighted behavior to exploit the
rules for immediate benefit why because
you can't get there things are different
it seems the open question is then why
are endogenous legislative procedures
not changed regularly to meet
overwhelming short-term goals
so basically legislators are short term
oriented to have opportunities to change
goals to meet immediate needs but for
some reason they seem not to more often
than not I think that's an important
puzzle that if it can be solved can help
solve a lot of other problems and learn
a lot about other institutions as well
I'll just put a coat on that very
quickly in one of my all-time favorite
articles in political science Jerry
Kramer makes a distinction that I've
always found useful in PhD PhD classes
the distinction is between learning and
understanding so Kramer says that theory
by which he meant formal deductive
theory with explicit and rigorous
assumptions is the source of enhances
sufficient for learning and likewise
empirical knowledge observation is
sufficient for learning but it's only
when you combine learning and
understanding it's only when you combine
theory and empirical work that you reach
you extend beyond theory and get to
level of understanding and I think that
we've learned a lot about legislative
rules in the last few decades beginning
around the time David Mayhew suited up
for action but I think we still don't
understand legislative procedures in the
deep sense of kramer and yet I think
there are central importance to
understanding legislators and political
institutions more generally I also think
it's not a fluke that the two questions
and Alec and Eric pose respectively are
about number one important thing that
you have learned a number two an open
question that is something we still know
something about but don't yet understand
I'm a in a sense doubly embarrassed at
being on this roundtable I do like
roundtables because I'm on the gaseous
side of the continuum but the I'm
embarrassed to be sitting between a
Keith and Bob who for so long have done
so much theoretically and empirically a
shape a field in which I'm pretty much
still a young newcomer not young in
other ways but young and in that ways
and a bit embarrassed to be answering
comprehensive exam questions when in
fact I'll confess I never had to take a
comprehensive exam in political science
because I earned a degree in history so
the I'm doubly vexed here signs here and
I didn't take copper into the ether
well the and I should also perhaps add
just by way of a very brief introduction
that I can come to the study of Congress
through sets of questions in the
subfield of American political
development that I found I couldn't
answer without grappling with Congress
questions about race and the liberal
tradition questions about social
democracy questions about State Building
questions about temporality etc all of
these central themes in the subfield of
American political development a
subfield which I come to believe in a my
imprint with John Lipinski and others in
saying has paid not enough attention to
Congress not to speak of political
historians who rarely write about
Congress and my main interests in in
working on Congress or less with the
institution as such that would interest
me and fascinates me
then with a substantive questions about
outputs of lawmaking and how they shape
and reshape the the nature of the
American polity now to answer the first
of the two questions about what the
interesting and important things I may
have learned as many of you know I've
I've been focusing my work on
representation and representatives from
the south and their role in national
politics inspired in the first instance
by V Okies chapters on Congress in
southern politics and as it's worth
recalling from the founding until the
mid-1960s
these representatives were selected by a
limited electoral citizen citizenry and
nearly to a person strove to maintain
regional autonomy in matters of race
this was true of members from the 15
slave states before the Civil War and
the 17 states that practiced mandatory
racial segregation after Oklahoma joined
West Virginia as a new state with a
formal legal hierarchy of race relations
and after the Voting Rights Act these
states underwent three decades of
partisan transformation that ultimately
shifted as we all know that regions
embeddedness in the Democratic Party to
the Republican Party and it's that
process I think that as Richard Benson's
question pointed to fundamentally
underpin many if not all of the trends
that we saw in the fascinating panel
this morning now in my own work on the
New Deal and fair deal I've was both
surprised and impressed by the decisive
and changing role of Southern Democrats
both in temporal and substantive terms
from the Nira to conscription from
soldier voting to the various national
security acts crucial outcomes depended
on how those representatives assess the
implications of national policy for the
distinctive southern social economic and
political system these capacities
moreover were not constant temporarily
there was a shift from being a veto
group when they composed a minority of
the majority party after the 1932
elections to being the most active
shaper of lawmaking after southerners
became the majority of the majority
party
after 1938 and in the 80th Congress the
large majority of the minority party in
analyzing their role in shaping modern
America I found the conceptual language
of parties factions and regions to be
inadequate nor is the familiar
organization of congressional behavior
based on ideal points in two dimensions
sufficient as it leaves unexamined the
intensity and content of preferences and
their lexical ordering and to the second
question more briefly what is the most
interesting and important open question
put down the following which I'll read
it is an old question that remains
painfully unresolved in the early 1950s
Bob Dole identified atomic energy as an
issue in
which and I quote the political
processes of democracy do not operate by
that he meant legislative processes and
he concluded that short article by
projecting that this zone would grow how
to think about the role the legislature
in national security matters remains
insufficiently
explored of course we know a lot about
delegation and a lot about the
assertions of executive power but is
this now a permanent zone of what
Clinton Rossiter once labeled
constitutional dictatorship both
normatively and substantively what
should be the role of Congress in this
fear of issues these issues are related
to the policy makes politics literature
identified with Ted LOI and the students
of substantive representation such as
David Brady yogi Clawson David may you
and Barbara Sinclair in the 1960s 70s
and 80s colleagues who sought to
understand how congressional behavior
alters by issue areas but from the
perspective of democracy and democratic
theory national security raises
questions that transcend and supersede
the tools and analyses that that
literature elaborated and hence remains
an open question
I feel like an orphan at the end of the
round table in fact I don't even have
any table here as I understood the
charge it was from Ellen was to say
something briefly it's sort of in
something sort of interesting and at the
same time empirical empirically accepted
and though struck me as contradictory
things so I thought I would do is offer
two arguments for two seemingly
contradictory things which I both
believe and really not contradictory and
that therefore there's a chance you
might find them interesting or at least
controversial and possibly empirically
except I don't at least one of the two
of my baby so they're both related to to
the current electorate and polarization
one argument one thing I want to say is
something about us about what you find
if you look at the national election
study and look at how boaters view the
parties in terms of relative themselves
ideologically okay what's it is
basically an argument that there's a
heck of a lot of sorting going on as we
all know and perhaps more than you
thought and secondly at the same time
that there's a lot of desire for divided
government perhaps perhaps because of
the growing polarization so first so
let's say it look at the American
American national election study take
the 2008 study or any years going back
the past couple of decades maybe a whole
bunch of years and you look at only
those voters who buy whatever extenders
you're using know the Democrats at the
left of the Republicans that's your
standard for ideological literacy or
whatever you want to call it okay
ideally you might want to take about
four different issues if they're if
they're if the data is available for
that study and so these are voters who
place the Democrats left of the
Republicans and the question is where do
they see themselves relative to the two
parties okay of this group or maybe
roughly half the electorate
the other half don't know or something
that one-third see one of the parties
just exactly where they're gonna be just
right no matter how you slice it another
third are in the middle only one third
the other third are out there one of the
extremes other words one-third left of
the Democrats one-third rivalry popping
spray evenly balanced okay that's how
you do it now you look at my party of
course and you see the Democrats don't
make any mistakes as though virtually no
right-wing Democrats no left-wing
Republicans they don't make mistakes in
fact the Democrats are more Democrats
clearly more Democrats are to the left
to see themselves to the left of the
party then to the right of the party and
Republicans to the right of their party
so basically you can see this is sort of
the generator if we might say is the
current politics now you say what about
the independence we forgot about the
independence there like a big share of
the electorate right we forget about
them and they they must be in the middle
right no your dependents are the most
polarized of all in a sense that there's
more independence either on the left of
the right then Democrats or Republicans
are on the left to the right that's a
big amount but it's surprising that this
is true so in other words there's a lot
of people out there in the left or the
right who call themself independence but
haven't he have yet to be sorted and
that I think is another interesting fact
so anyway we have so Micra is getting
increasingly polarized in that sense
okay at the same time we have we have
the demand for divided government might
be getting greater in the sense that I
used to like to think of it in terms of
demand for what I would think is
ideological balance this is an argument
that's familiar in the case of
congressional elections and somewhat
controversial but the notion that the
source of midterm loss is a demand for
ideological balance so the way to block
liberal Obama is to let conservative
Republicans and so on but I think it's
broader than that I mean I think I think
it's impart of a general argument that
people vote for one office conditional
what's going on on the other so ortho or
what they expect to be going on together
so for example works out for so for
example if you have
democratic precedence you expect
Republican covers why are there so many
Republican governors now because you
have a Democratic president why and so
it works obviously across federal levels
and in fact it works across from top to
from not only from president I would say
not only from president affecting
Congress rather lower offices but also
lower office is affecting the
presidential choice so I'm working with
one person in this room who Brad doesn't
agree named and we've written a paper
that I use that that the vote for that
who your governor is affects you vote
for president opposite in other words
every Republican governor in Wisconsin
Scott Walker you're more likely to elect
Obama in Wisconsin and speculatively it
works speculatively it works as a reason
why we have so many Republican
presidents for a long period of time why
do why we have a Democratic electorate
like tizen our Nixon a Reagan and Bush
why did that happen
contribute spec your speculatively
course because we had a Democratic
Congress they elected Republicans in
part to block the Democratic Congress
how did Clinton and then Obama have a
relatively easy time getting reelected
because they admit term they lucked into
a Republican Congress which might have
made it a lot might have made it a lot
easier and this is a final comment about
how ideological balance might seem to
work look at elections for governor as a
function to vote for president New
Jersey and Virginia both have elections
for governor the year after the
presidential election so that before the
honeymoon even wears off you might say
well what's the initial expectation well
maybe the vote has the country voted for
President Lee just a year before but no
they vote opposite the last seven
elections in New Jersey for governor
they vote an opposite party of the
president just elected last seven
elections for governor of Virginia
opposite the party it's just elected
presidents what it's sort of
counterintuitive a but so it's an easy
call to predict Governor Christie
probably get reelected
we might also expect a Republican
governor of Virginia my theory is
correct yeah so anyway there so on the
one hand we have this force is pulling
the parties apart obviously separate
from each other at the same time the
somehow produces had perhaps an
increasing demand for for divided
government or balance of some kind and
that's that's my story
excuse me one more Alan I'm gonna I'm
gonna skip party and go to Part B
we're gonna thanks okay um it's about
the question is I forgotten exactly what
the question is something to what we
might be well you might be thinking
about or investigating or doing or
rethinking and I have a there are a lot
of answers but there's a particular one
it's kind of a niche that comes from
teaching and reading these days not
writing I'm not writing anything about
this it has to do with the the the pool
world's pool Rosenthal roll-call
congressional role called data sets
which now go back two and a quarter
centuries after all which is the
magnificent accomplishment they so far
as I know unimpeachable as though I
wouldn't know unimpeachable as an
arithmetic or mathematical at the price
somewhat separate from that is the
interpretation of the data sets by
imposing words on them or adapting them
to ordinary thinking ordinary usage of
language or ordinary conversations and
politics and they're I think with some
there some problems that we might give
some attention to to improving the
interpretation so to speak of the base
of this is widely influential
arithmetic or mathematical Enterprise I
think there are a couple of problems I
think I think there are a couple of
problems of interpretation of what is
this I think we need to rethink rethink
they rethink comparing levels of
polarization across long periods of time
by relying simply on the earth with ik
of the bull Rosenthal datasets I'm not
at issue was whether we've got more
polarization right now in some respects
that we had 30 years ago I think the
answer is yes and actually there are a
lot of different data sets showing
different kinds of things some of them
put in front of us by Gary this morning
which show that so it's really not an
issue it issue I think is it's looking
over two and a quarter centuries it's an
American political development kind of
thing at least and I think that a three
problem three distinct problems arise in
making comparisons over a long period of
time using just the arithmetic and in
and and employing such the phrase
polarization without any prepositional
phrases afterwards such as among home
about what but this plane using it as a
gerund polarization is more polarization
now than there was 50 years ago that
less than there was a hundred years ago
or hundred fifty years ago those kinds
of comparisons are out there we see of
journalists make them and we make them
three kinds of problems one is the
familiar one of sorting this often we
don't know we're confused about whether
we're talking about polarization between
the parties in Congress or polarization
to cool that is to say regardless of
whatever's going on regarding the
parties in Congress and there's the
continual source of confusion or
anything in our heads there about that
differentiation secondly and this has
been adverted to and Verta to today at
least in one respect it's that the
patterns could be to a substantial
degree I think artifacts of differences
in processes the way processes they're
happy
now the obvious instance there for is
that in recent times the agenda control
mechanism is very different and they
tend to blind out non partisan there are
not ideological differentiation they
tend to do that probably so why don't
you think about that how do we think
about that but this is not the only kind
of process difference that could cloud
our minds there are others other
possibilities so you take 225 years many
differences of customs in roll call vote
what kind of stuff is being voted on or
probably of some importance
I remember reading something years ago a
nice paper by David Brady nice paper
very elegantly done about roll call
voting it's a time series and he there's
something coming out of the 1940s and at
the end if I know what it was that is
there's some big change in the in the
pattern and I had a suspicion that it
was just reflected on polarization or
loaded onto it somehow have to do with a
change of the kinds of stuff they were
voting on different kinds of emotions
they may be more often voting on this
kind of motion rather than that kind of
motion or may be doing it more commonly
I really couldn't tell I wanted to look
under the hood to see what they were
voting on well what were the components
of the data set for this Congress is
supposed to that Congress in the kinds
of stuff being voted on that that's
point number two there could be again
the differences over time could be at
least partly artifacts of differences in
process but there's a third I think
difficulty it's this one that the the
datasets they were all called data sets
over daughter try fade they have a
flavor of ordinality to them as opposed
to cardinality and by that I mean the
following it is the what they will they
they'll take the combat whatever it is
in a Congress and put boundaries
additive 0 or 100 and play that way but
it's the intuition that in common sense
terms are in the way we do history or
the way we take about life
a situation like the one in the 1850s
where they're fussing about whether to
go to Civil War and kill each other in
the hundreds of thousands it's a more
polarized situation then it's one where
they're voting about what are the rates
the minimum wage a buck or two bucks
which is the more common kind of
differentiation these days and the
arithmetic will not make that
differentiation or at least it won't
make it very well or very much and I
can't I can't get it out of my head that
there's something Cardinal going on here
that it's just that the public is
interested in and thinking about
polarization that is not measurable
through the datasets or at least not
very measurable through the datasets so
I I would guess that in common sense
terms the most polarized time in
American history in Congress would be
the 1850s but how do you show that
arithmetic alee mathematically it's not
easy to do implicitly there's a cardinal
yardstick out there and I don't know
what it is or how to measure it but I
can't get it out of my head I think we
should just stop making comparisons over
a century or two saying and the basis of
congressional local data that there's
more polarization now than there was
then a century ago or two centuries ago
without being very clear to put on some
prepositional phrases and some
qualifications showing exactly what
we're doing that's point number one
that's argument number one about
interpretive the other argument has to
do with the the content of roll-call
cleavages are in fact matter of the
whole role called casting world of
experience over to what in 25 years that
is to say the issue of content how do we
think about that
you know how do we how do we label it
how do we label it we get a dimension
out of it after all the first dimension
a second dimension how do we label it I
think that's a very complicated kind of
at the price to put labels on the
back along curries of ways for example
to take it back a century or a century
and a half I think this is an extreme
instance of analytic difficulty I think
a conceptual difficulty that the terms
liberal and conservative they display
don't work in the US as as as presented
in the 19th century they just don't work
dart has left three bright work and they
therapy and sense of work with 19th
century differentiation you know it
works here and there now and then you
can play with it but Karl Marx was
rooting for Lincoln and the Republicans
to the 1860s to give a clear example of
oddity going back that far that's
extreme instance of a labeling
difficulty but the problem is what is
more general in what we know I seems to
be about the roll call patterns is that
there are alliances of people against
each other and they tend to it that they
tend to persist not just within Congress
but over a period of at least short
periods of several congresses and that's
very retailing it very important to know
that after all but we don't know except
by looking carefully what those
alliances are the issue contents of
those alliances are it is it's we just
we'd have to look we just we should be
very careful about adjectives using
adjectives and nouns
I mean one way to start and often a
frame of mind in dealing with this is an
end going stance of extreme nominalism
at these things they had the same issue
by issue by issue I mean it's a issue by
issue by issue it said just look and be
very careful about generalizing about
content over or even you know a decade
or two decades two three decades he
could surpass us it's not what it was in
the 1840s nineteen for 1940s forget
about the 19th century it's just not
that's not the same thing liberalism is
not the same thing in west of the 1950s
and we should know this and think about
it
great well I'd like to thank the
panelists for a series of extremely
thought-provoking I would go so far as
to say extremely deep and wise
observations about the state of our
knowledge and exciting ideas for what we
ought to do and in the case of David's
discussion what we ought to stop doing
right away so thank you very much